a big night for america first
politicians and a bad one for the far
left a trump endorsement boosting j.d
vance to victory in ohio's republican
senate primary
now this campaign i really think was a
referendum on what kind of a republican
party we want and what kind of a country
we want
we went to battle do we want a
republican party that stands for the
donors who write checks to the club for
growth or do we want a republican party
for the people right here in ohio ladies
and gentlemen we just answered the
question
the far left having no such luck as aoc
backed nina turner lost her house
primary challenge and tim ryan the dem
who is set to face off with j.d vance in
november
doesn't want anything to do with joe
biden
president biden will you invite
president biden to come campaign for you
look we welcome everybody's support um
but i will be the face of this campaign
i don't think you know surrogates are
going to play a huge role here i want
people to get to know me i want my i
want to control my message i want it to
be my face and my background my record
all right we'll get to tim ryan in a
minute but you know here you have uh jd
vance dana who's uh
third or fourth in line uh trump then
lays his hand on his shoulder and you
take someone from third or fourth and he
wins the primary it changes the victory
everything yeah you can see in fact if
you look at the others that were running
how they
lost and he gained their their uh voters
so it mattered it mattered a lot and i
also think the timing of it mattered it
happened at just the right time so that
he could uh surge to victory i think uh
one of the thing when he was talking
there about what kind of park republican
party are we going to have and we don't
want these people
i mean
you're going to need all the republican
votes because this is going to be one of
the biggest races now trump won the
state by eight points i think it
definitely stays republican but tim ryan
is somebody who is getting a lot of
grassroots support now the left will try
to say that he's very moderate he check
his voting record
it's 100
with the democrats and then yesterday he
said he wanted to codify roe v wade so
that will be an issue that he has to
deal with i'm also very interested in
the fact that aoc thinks she's going to
have all these additional squad members
that join her
after the midterms and so far that is
not turning out to be the case well you
know it's interesting that apparently
greg the fake news according to jd vance
wanted to write about the death of
donald trump's agenda now the left has
been bringing up trump and now with this
new uh with this supposed decision
they're really bringing up magga and now
trump is showing the power that he has
they need donald trump right now they
need somebody they need a demon and i
think these outcomes are more related
less to trump than the democrats
disastrous embrace of the hard left
wokism right
it's creating and you can see it a
pendulum swing and you're not and that's
why you're getting a lot of young
candidates sometimes it'll be a little
bit colorful but you saw a lot of you
you see a lot of change going on but
there's one variable in this in these
elections that it also explained the
supreme court leak and why it was
necessary over 230 000 more republicans
turned out in ohio than they did in 2018
it's the highest turnout ever there were
160 000 fewer dems that came out to vote
that's an enthusiasm enthusiasm gap so
wide brian stelter could walk through it
yeah so hence the leak the leak was
essentially a steroid for enthusiasm
yeah but you know harold when you talk
about an enthusiasm gap you know
virginia showed us that the suburban
moms are coming out to protect their
children in schools
this enthusiasm gap now that the dems
have leaked are they going to change
those suburban moms to now come out and
fight for roe versus wade as opposed and
keep them in the democrat i think i
think that the suburban moms
how they respond to what's happening
with roe v wade will be a really
significant issue and i think that in
some ways it does bail out the democrats
who were flailing had nothing
they had no point they didn't know where
the hell they were going you know i am
in nina turner chantal brown's
congressional district uh it was
reassuring to me to see the democrats go
for chantel brown
who is in democratic terms of a moderate
competing nina turner who's endorsed by
the squad and aoc and and so forth
i also think that tim ryan is the only
democrat statewide who has a chance
against the republican i am stunned by
j.d vance's victory
the impact of trump's endorsement is
something that is breathtaking i don't
know that there's anything anything like
that in my lifetime in american politics
the fact that he took vance who was
doing 10 percent and then suddenly he
was doing 20 plus percent in the in the
republican primary is stunning to me so
it's trump's party ohio's a republican
state uh abortion is the is the one
issue where suburban moms might be
motivated uh i i've always thought that
abortion
has always been the secret issue
that i remember a conversation i had
with sean hannity in 2016 i said after
the debates in in
las vegas
i said you know some i think abortion is
really the issue that no one's going to
talk about it but it's really the issue
now they're talking about it i i wonder
how it plays out you know joey jd vance
comes out of this primary the favorite i
mean and but you've got he's going to be
running against tim ryan
who won 70 of the democrat vote so tim
ryan is strong so the question is you
know in the general election does donald
trump does he carry him the victory
given the eight points you said
something when you're talking to greg
you said the death of donald trump's
agenda whoever wrote that needs to hang
it up and go do something else for a
living the only thing more popular among
conservatives than donald trump is
donald trump's agenda donald trump's
agenda doesn't have the tweets or
january 6th or any of the personality of
donald trump it is results driven and it
is what people enjoyed in contrast
against what they're living now jd vance
is the prime example of that j.d vance
is not donald trump but he embraced
donald trump's agenda that's how he
earned the endorsement and that's why
he's going to win another example is
brian kemp brian kemp is everything
america first except for the favor of
donald trump and he's going to do well
in georgia donald trump's agenda with or
without donald trump is the winning
ticket and that's why i think a ron
desantis backed by donald trump would
would blow the doors off of it in 2024.
all right democratic senate candidate
tim ryan will be on special report with
brett bayer so check that one out and up
next comedy chaos an armed assailant
attacks comedian dave chappelle i went
on brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now